yet another big american company going
woke disney caving to the liberal mob
and pledging to help repeal the new
parental rights bill that just signed
into law by florida governor ron
desantis which democrats in the media
have completely lied about and called
bigoted the bill bans instruction of
sexual orientation or gender identity in
kindergarten through third grade
desantis firing back at disney while
calling out some of the obvious double
standards
for a company like disney uh to say that
they this bill should have never passed
first of all tucker they weren't saying
anything when this was going through the
house they only started doing this
because the mob the woke mob came after
him but put that aside for them to say
that them as a california-based company
are going to work to take those
california values and overturn a law
that was duly enacted and as you said
supported by a strong majority of
floridians they don't run this state if
we had done a bill that prohibited
talking about the abuse of uyghurs in
china disney would have supported that
legislation
and a new controversy for disney as we
get leaked videos of top executives at
the company discussing a plan to go woke
at its theme parks listen
last summer we removed all of the um
gendered greetings and relationship to
our life skills so now they know it's
hello everyone or hello friends when we
brought the fireworks back to the magic
kingdom we no longer say ladies and
gentlemen boys and girls we say dreamers
of all ages
gender neutral disney greg
by the way
sorry but when you can't even say ladies
and gentlemen anymore or boys and girls
what is happening in the world sorry but
would you like to go ahead i have
sometimes just like it's so weird
it's so pathetic isn't it you can't go
to a theme park and you can't hear the
words ladies and gentlemen boys and
girls
i mean what's going on
great i'm interested what is going on
i'll tell you what's going on
let me let me tell you my best
posh accent
um
do you mind if i just yeah go abandon
what why i think it's nuts is it
what you've got and i discussed this
with you last night on your show you've
got this small group of very vocal very
woke people
very active online and they bully
companies into following their narrow
world view
and i admire the companies like netflix
in the dave chappelle
uproar i admired spotify when they stood
by joe rogan that is the way to deal
with the mob because the mob very
quickly gets bored and moves on and
guess what dave chappelle still on
netflix joe rogan is still on spotify
that's the right way to respond disney
began this with their new ceo saying
we're not going to be political great
great because by the way if you are
going to be political as desantis
rightly pointed out then let's hear what
you've got to say about the genocide of
the uyghur muslims in china right which
we'll never hear from disney because
they make too much money from a chinese
box office market so if you're going to
be political be consistent morally and
in terms of your apparent outrage but of
course they don't want to do that they
want to be bullied by this white mob
into doing something they didn't
instinctively want to do and now they're
being sucked in aren't they into this
woke trap and they apologize by the way
it never stops the moment you apologize
they keep coming and it looks like this
woke mob judge probably came from disney
itself you had a lot of really loud
employees probably in their 30s and 20s
just screaming at executives ah don't
say gay don't say gay and and then they
they reacted and overreacted okay two
things the bill doesn't say don't say
gay that's number one the second point
is since when do california values since
when should they be instilled in florida
and the third point is good for desantis
for saying you know what stay in your
own lane i'm the governor of this state
and don't tell me what to do and i i
have to tell you if disney is so woke i
was talking to some of the producers
this morning and then you talked to them
yeah i do i think they're wonderful
they're so smart anyway they were
talking and they have they have young
children they said there's a movie that
disney did called turning red
and that the kids are so mean to each
other and that they call each other
losers and the one producer in
particular said you know they should
explain why they're teaching our kids to
be mean and call each other names and
like losers while they're trying to make
like they're the peacemakers on earth
they're including everyone when they're
really not and so i just think disney
ought to stay in their own lane should
we get to greg now
yes
i don't think they've gone far enough i
think tinker bell should be a dude
a big strapping dude but you know ticker
bro
to peter's point
woke-ism has this enormous superpower
which you could take stuff that you
loved you really loved and it could turn
into poison whether it's pro athletes
that you admired or tv shows that you
watched or musicians the land of lakes
butter yes
but the interesting thing about it is
there's no they offer no replacement for
what they intend to destroy so they go
there they go okay this has to be this
way because you're an oppressor this is
evil and corrupt but then you go what do
you do and they go we don't have any
creative
skills we don't have actually any talent
our only talent is to condemn you and
then we move on the bill like you said
does not say it never says do not say
gay but the thing is the media knew that
the dems know that but they colluded to
manufacture the story just the way they
buried uh that laptop story they created
and manufactured this story because they
are terrified of desantis becoming a
candidate because they know he's going
to crush the democrats uh there's
another thing too about
it kind of bugs me that they keep
calling this bill controversial and it's
controversial because it was
misrepresented but also when you when
you look at it it's like don't teach
gender and sexuality to kids third grade
and under how is that unreasonable if
you i got if you my counter views if you
really want to talk to a five-year-old
or a seven-year-old or an eight-year-old
about their sexuality and gender that's
on you you're a pervert you're a weirdo
i don't give a damn if you're a teacher
or a sex ed there's something weird if
you want to share your sexuality like i
want to tell little billy that i am a
pansexual woodland nymph
you know
you go see your shrink that's for your
shrink you leave the kids out of it
that's the idea that that we are like
forfeiting
we're forfeiting this high ground
because we aren't we're scared of being
called i don't know homophobic sensitive
bs man
when greg brought up about teaching
people at that age about
sex and things like that in florida they
don't have sex education until sixth
grade
so why would the liberals insist
that you would teach a kindergartner
first and second and third grader about
transgenderism where you don't even get
to all that stuff anyway until six not
only that but you think the political
part of it so mark caputo uh reported on
this poll that florida democrats primary
voters there they agree with the
republican stance on this but it's
controversial but yes it's controversial
and they keep the the left keeps walking
in the democratic party into this
cul-de-sac where now they don't know how
to get out of it right so um you'll see
this in lots of different things where
the democrats are like well these
corporations bail us out we have another
example right there in georgia remember
when the
mlb pulled the game and they put it in
denver and they hadn't read the bill and
it was unfair and it turns out that
coca-cola should never have done that
and even stacey abrams was like oh
actually no we didn't we didn't mean
that but they keep stepping on a rake
and hitting themselves in the face
worker retention and employee
satisfaction is super important right
now we have
four million people resign their jobs in
february and move to other jobs there's
a 3.7 percent
unemployment rate that means that
employers are in this position of how do
we keep people happy well they
at disney they decided to basically say
okay this small loud group we're going
to go with them there's a small group of
conservatives that work at disney as
well
what about all the commercial disney
employees where are their rights to have
their opinions and the other thing i
just want to point out i thought that
rick grinnell made a really good point
so he worked for president in the trump
administration and the bush
administration he said that it just
pointed out that disney studios said
nothing when trump had the push to deal
with the 60 countries around the world
that have being gay as illegal right
where you can be put to death and disney
sells in all of those countries and they
never said a word the work the woke
employees didn't care about that but
they take this bill
misrepresent it and then that leads to
these consequences is disney world going
to be gender neutral in china
i highly doubt that i highly doubt it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else